hey guys Lucy here with a quick GameSpot
news update for you Microsoft could be
on the verge of a graphics card
breakthrough with the arrival of DirectX
12 as the new API will allow PC users to
combine GPUs from different
manufacturers presently PC users who
want to double the number of graphics
cards attached to their motherboard are
restricted by the manufacturer so two
nvidia geforce cards have the same type
would work via sli and two AMD Radeon
cards can unite by a crossfire but these
cannot be mixed and matched however
Microsoft is preparing a major
announcement at GDC where it is expected
to explain that dx12 can combine all the
different graphics resources in a system
and treat them as though they were a
single card the rumor first emerged on
Tom's Hardware earlier this week a
source connected to the matter who asked
not to be named her since explained to
GameSpot that the feature is genuine key
to the process is how DirectX 12 will
bind multiple GPUs together
according to Tom's Hardware the text
then treats the entire graphics
subsystem as a single more powerful
graphics card
thus users get the robustness of running
a single GPU but with multiple graphics
cards such a breakthrough could bring
about new levels of convenience for PC
and Suzi's and developers alike for the
first time it will also mean that
multiple GPUs can pool their memory in
theory this means that installing 2
gigabytes GPUs into a system look at the
end user a usable 4 gigabytes of memory
and let the current system which would
only give a users 2 gigabytes of memory
so is this it is life as we know it
gonna change are you pumped for DirectX
12 let me know in the comment section
below for all the latest make sure you
stay tuned to game spot.com
you